ここは都内某所にある
てもオサレな図書館
ここには子どもも大人も
おじいちゃんもおばあちゃんも
院内の集まって
大好きな方を静かに読む素敵な空間です
伊勢が今日のとの間は少し雰囲気が違う
様子
奥から一人の
いつもは見ない顔のお客様が来られました
なんだか怪しい不審者みたい
どう見ても迷惑行為ポストな顔をしている
この男が
図書館で何をするのでしょうか
雲上もきっけてますねこれちゃん
募集したんですけどもせっかくと召喚に来
ているということで待つ女に質問コーナー
歯数たくまづめ冊ほど質問コーナーをこの
神聖な
が図書館でやっていきたいとおもいます
大船プールサインですテンション上がって
めっちゃ声出しちゃうんですけども格好の
静かな図書館だったら声も出せない皆さん
の迷惑になってしまう
ピクシーズが超えて真面目に質問に答えて
いきたいとおもいます宜しくお願いします
[音楽]
分離せるに交際規則年で文系に行くと決め
ているんですがその世界史+に保証という
か日本 shuttle かでもどうし
たらいいかわからないんです当初敵目に
おいてアドバイスをいただけないでしょう
かなことね世界一にですか初ように僕は
ですね尻をとってましたと違いん
本当にこれは彼はどっちで興味がある方と
思います日本の力次ぐ2だったら日本史
[音楽]
世界して好きな方を選ぶので僕は良いと
思います少し
興味がなく方を勉強してみてください本当
に真面目にするんですかいやもう末尾にし
ます分かります彼の状況図書館でください
ねしずくまず目に遭わせていただきます
将来の夢がないです適当に決めてください
将来の夢がないし適当に決めてください
いいでしょう
なんか好きなものとかあれは分かりやすい
と思うんですけどもなんかいいのないかな
宇宙飛行シーバスのボケなのに社長学生
時代というふうに行ったほうがありますか
選ばれなかったらでキャビアのせいか1
週間話しやすく1つか甘かったと思います
小学校からバスケやってたんですけど
そんなに上手じゃなかったんですよ
ちょっと慎重が大きいくらいで何か監督
さんにめざ草シュートの練習しろって言わ
れてからすごいシュートもでしょ
からかなり調達しますそれからなんカス
ためみたいになって気がします
バスケットボールで手に入れれば売上
できる子
助っ人ポルテ点入れば活躍できるスポーツ
なって
頑張ってみてくださ先ほども
[音楽]
ん
すみません
日証金市大福が出願先はどのぐらいの時期
に決まってましたか大学の左官詐欺でしょ
センター試験受けてから室が咲き変えまし
たとそういうぐらい全然考えてなくても
いいんじゃないカーンててからなんとなく
その学部とか決めてますけど本当に行き
たいか工程夏の編成が出てから全然大丈夫
だと思います頑張れない時に持つ美女わけ
で方法を教えてほしい考えだ
僕もありますよ頑張れないだけもにして
かかれないんだよ
彼等はもう
愛知天地ように遊ぶ日に当ててゆっくり
休んだらいいと思いますがんばれ
とまだ j の出張がヤバい時どうすれば
いい人ってさん人に嫉妬するものを出すよ
られませんってこの本なのでもう気にし
ないように頑張ってください気にしないで
待ってまして全然真面目じゃないと本当に
祭します当初感じですよ
こう言うと絶対出せないです4月今回は
真面目にやらせていただきます直に何も
ありませんが応援してくださいがんばれ
普通自動車の運転免許を取得してそこそこ
年生が経ちますが未だに高速道路が怖くて
乗れません麺が作れたら速さが強かったり
克服してるんですが何かいい方法あります
か100個
僕の最初強かったでしょ
はい
ハンドルもちょっと揺らすだけですよ
じゃあね c 深いしてもらっていいです
かそれで図書館前ですすいません
わけナイスッとポスター1枚とも緊張して
いるんですか私はとても人見知りで
プレゼントならた目線が人に彼の羽鳥声が
暮れてしまったねそれが緩いままで学校
休みたくなってしまうのですがこれからは
変わりたいでぜひアドバイスが欲しいです
と前にも緊張せずに話せるのはちょっとね
ぼく部苦手なんですよこういうカメラ向い
て立ったので喋れるんですけど
人の周りとか1-0とかほんと苦手で
プレゼントも苦手です
その甲斐は本当に苦手なのでこれ候補です
ね仲良くしよねー仲良くしようね君たち
できるだけ全力でピーマンて避けてほしい
ええまあを言うせないかよ
あんぐらんねんこれ
を図書館じゃないのと言われたっけ
はじめに相談です私はよく友達以上に気を
使いすぎているのか飛ばす一つかれる
ちょっと思ってしまうことがあります友達
のことはダイスジョブズがそう思って
しまうことは嫌ですどうしたらいい
でしょうか長文ですみませんしますね
俺も姉と安達というときキー使うと思い
ますよ
ブーバー地大
アーレちょいアーチャー一
間んじゃってねぇ
ねぇ私は何ヘアメイクは何をしても調子が
出ないなぁ時にどうやって乗り越えますか
断乳をしておりません
さっきも言ったと思うんですけど知恵が
上がらない時だと思うんですよねよしても
勝者がてないと思っている時でもセックス
が上手いなでしこ願っています
な方がたくさんあります投稿
goo
年齢=彼氏いないんだけどまま成立して
しまいました私の王子様とこう
[音楽]
な彼氏にないと人は最初で最後の彼氏かも
しれないんですよ
的なご質問ですけど嫌われてないのに
ちょっとしたことで嫌われたと思うか手を
突っ込んでしまいますどうすればいいと
思いますが避難
[音楽]
人に期待しないようにしてるから
あげていると思い込んでもくる少ない
だけを吸っていきましょう大学共通てした
本番まで100日を切りました模試の結果
があまりよくなくて心が不安定です何も手
に付かないときなど解決法や助言がでも
教えてください何もてもつかない感覚町田
分かりません
232000と草栄養主て分かっている人
がいること
そプレッシャーになってつかなくなると
思うんですけど何も考えずにやって
くださいせる時はも積ませる昔て分かり
ます
のことを気にしなくていい学校の事もお金
のことも何も注意しないでくださいだった
が来る見てください
微分と暴れてください
うわぁ
わーい
ua
持っています
えっ
[音楽]
今皆知らねーなんてなさそうだ今日7
こんななぜ強だけだぜ
[音楽]
voodoo
ブーブー
80へいへいの本の白い
ましたね
ぶー
[音楽]
ぶーっ
あった
[音楽]